are you aware of the time in which an 80
percent of abortions take place like the
state of gestation yeah that's a
relatively early first trimester okay do
you know the week perhaps I don't know
okay so 80 of abortions occur before
week nine and you know you say that
their babies are kicking and reacting
are you aware of what a nine week old
fetus looks like oh yes very well yes
can you describe it to me yeah yeah well
by a really I suppose by the 10th week
that's that's uh you know especially
when you go in and you have your babies
you go in for an eight-week appointment
by the eight week appointment they can
tell you the sex of of your baby which
is amazing that's how well formed they
are already uh by the 10-week
appointment they've got basically all of
their features formed in a very
rudimentary way but they're already
quite formed and you can you can look
and they no longer look like a little
tadpole entirely they look much more
like a human being and they've got their
little fingers already in their little
toes
I actually have pictures for you right
so
this is nine weeks
this is what a nine week fetus looks
like well let me see I would like to if
you want to look at that and you would
like to look at that
you can look at this oh great yeah yeah
and I know that you it's not like any
ultrasound I've ever looked at though
yeah I know that's why I brought them
because this isn't an ultrasound no this
is a nine week fetus and a petri dish in
a Petri dish why do you have the thing
in the petri dish
to Discount misinformation that is
spread about this issue but just like
you do how did the baby get into the
petri dish it's I believe these are
aborted
and so this so you're saying that a baby
that has been sucked out and dismembered
looks a little bit different they aren't
abort they aren't dismembered because
there isn't enough of them the fetus is
barely recognizable to the naked eye how
is that baby aborted so at nine weeks
it's usually just a pill that expels the
fetus what does the pill all the pill
does is expel the base yeah it basically
makes the uterine lining not able to
um or the fetus not able to adhere to
the uterine lining and it shuts it it's
there's various mechanisms so the there
are what are some of the other
mechanisms
well it depends on the week of gestation
let's say around 10 weeks we're talking
about so I think after 10 weeks is they
what they will do is it's no longer
going to be a pill they essentially
um inject like saline solution and they
inject in it it removes it from the
uterine lining so a it's a basically a
poison no no it's flushing it's cleaning
out the uterus but it but it's uh
yeah I'm not saying it's cyanide or
something like that but it's you're
injecting a chemical into the uterus
usually like saline solution right but I
can if I put saline solution on a slug
it'll shrivel up and die yeah are you a
slug
did humans react the same way saline
solution as slugs do yes little babies
do actually no they just that's why it
connects it right no so this is the
connection between the mother between
the baby and the placenta and the mother
so and to flush out the poor little baby
so this is why I think it's really
ghastly and disingenuous of you to to no
I'm great I'm bringing this because you
consistently want to anthropomorphize
this issue you described the baby as
anthropomorphic you describe the baby as
a human
you did you said it's a human being it
is a human being but you know you're
accusing we have anthropomorphizing a
human being is a nine week old fetus
this is a nine week old fetus and I
bring this to try to address
misinformation about can I if you would
please allow me sure it's just really
ghastly to show a picture of a person
who's been killed and I apologize for
that but I do this apology implies that
you'll correct your behavior no not
doing that because people such as
yourself and there are different
multiple different websites that like to
share propaganda about this issue and I
am here to try to present a medically
accurate representation of what a murder
victim of what this issue is and when
you try to act as though it is murder I
want your audience to truly truly
understand what we are talking about
because I am not saying that a woman
with a desired pregnancy shouldn't feel
connected to her fetus that's not what
I'm saying I am saying when we are
having when we have a person with an
unwanted pregnancy
you cannot act as though their choice to
you know decide what is best for their
life and their body is murder when in
reality it is a living person standing
in front of you who's a living breathing
person with dreams and aspirations who
is a mother sister you know a daughter
wasn't no 59 of people who get abortions
are mothers with existing children and
so I just want all of them have existing
children
foreign
what's so confusing about this to me and
what's very silly I think about showing
pictures of aborted babies is it would
be as though if you were to ask me to
show you a picture of uh you know what
is an Italian guy in New York look like
okay and I showed you a picture of of a
of a young 25 year old Italian guy
splayed out on the street chopped up
bleeding dead
versus uh you know an Italian boy uh you
know eating a bowl of spaghetti or
something like that those two pictures
would look very very different and so
what the the trick the deception that
you've engaged in is you've taken a baby
who has been killed through abortion and
been separated from his mother and
splayed out and squeezed out and and
looks unrecognizable and you're
pretending no that that and you're what
you're pretending is that that cadaver
is uh what a baby who has not been
killed by his mother who is still in the
womb and who is growing and who's
exhibiting all the signs of life and it
was moving and it has little fingernails
no this was expelled it was not
dismembered if you look at this
primarily most of the tissue here is the
gestational Sac because the beginnings
of pregnancy the gestational sac and the
placenta are where some of the first
things created because that is what
attaches to the uterine lining and
provides the fetus with resources and
expels its waste that is primarily in
the first few weeks of pregnancy those
are the tissue contents that are created
before the fetus is really developed and
a nine week old fetus like I have here
the fetus itself is hardly
distinguishable to the human eye because
it's so small because it's so small and
so that is why I bring it up because so
hold on then the point because when you
present this you say well actually this
mostly isn't the fetus this mostly is
all this other stuff okay but then
you're not showing me what a fetus looks
like the fetus is in this picture right
but just very very small that is how so
how much of that picture is the fetus it
is indistinguishable to the human eye oh
so so now all you're saying is the fetus
at that stage it's not that uh
it's not that the fetus you know looks
like all this tissue actually isn't
really the fetus because you you can't
even see the feet exactly but you can't
really see it so now you're what you're
admitting is you're not showing people a
picture of a fetus you're showing people
a picture of a gestational Sac that's
been expelled with a tiny fetus if you
wanted to show people what a fetus looks
like at the age of 10 weeks in gestation
you would show them the fetus itself and
you would have to zoom in because it's a
very time you would have to use a
microscope you know this is the year of
Our Lord 2022 we have plenty of medical
Technologies which are being put to
Great evil but we we can also put them
to good use and show what the baby looks
like and it is simply a fact at 10 weeks
the baby looks like a baby and has
little fingernails and little toes do
you see the baby in this photo exactly
and that's what I'm telling you and
that's what I'm telling you know
microscopes are bringing a microscope so
when we talk about so when we talk about
abortion 80 of abortions this is the
contents and so when we talk about can I
please Michael I allowed you to finish
now well I appreciate you allowing me
that but I guess I just I don't want to
to move past this point your argument
now is not that the baby looks in a way
that you wouldn't expect the baby look
your argument is simply that abortion is
permissible at this stage because the
baby is very very small and you can't
see him in my photograph
no I am saying that abortion is
permissible because it is about the use
of the person's body who is pregnant and
I bring these photos because there is so
much misinformation put out about this
issue and like you well like you like to
say oh they react when you eat something
spicy they have little fingers and toes
when in reality the fetus at nine weeks
where 80 of abortions occur is hardly
distinguishable to the human eye so to
say that a living person sitting in
front of you with dreams and aspirations
and health situations and financial
situations mental situations that you
cannot possibly understand when they are
sitting in front of you telling you that
they do not consent whether it be
because they cannot or will not you know
endure a pregnancy you are saying that
the tissue within their uterus which is
primarily just a gestational sac and a
microscopic fetus that is worth more
than their desires about their own body
and you know when misinformation is
spread about this issue it is as if
these babies are dismembered and is this
very emotional and manipulative language
used when in reality that is not what
happens they've only been poisoned with
a pill and flushed out they haven't been
poisoned they've made the uterus an
inhabitable uninhabitable so then it is
expelled
yeah that sounds like poison to me